[Musique]
alors bon soir bonjour à la planète est
ici tandem canada en direct de montréal
11 ans 11 vendredi c'est la tradition
toutes les semaines c'est comme ça
recommence onze minutes après les
bulletins diffusion des bulletins de
nouvelles les grands bulletin la sto toi
maintenant de tam-tam de réveiller la
planète de vous informer
autour de la table autour de la table
une petite équipe post post moderne
alors marie claude simard est avec nous
bonjour marie clos pour un jour on
regarde quelqu'un merengues pour dire
bonjour aujourd'hui ici va nuire aux 28
on a perdu la mesure où 23 alors on peut
plus dire bonjour là on peut dire
bonjour à 90,97 c'est un peu flou sur la
97 je trouve et un peu de neige voilà
comme on dit la caméra rajeunissantes la
brigitte bardot c'est vrai alors avec
nous également nous avons notre bon
copain samir ben qui est avec nous oui
bonjour stéphane rose marie claude et
bonjour nos amis auditeurs sur internet
et ailleurs
samir y travaillent pour la section vol
pour la section exact alors on met fin à
la musique maestro on à sylvain du côté
de la technique qui nous appuient
également aujourd'hui alors vous
connaissez la tradition il ya un jeu
cette émission vous perdez des points
offerts mesure que la mission avances ou
encore vous en lance l'émission en temps
vous allez tenter de deviner le sujet de
l'émission à grasse une vidéo 5 images
malheureusement aujourd'hui puisque vous
êtes un nombre limité et que notre mois
de maistre c'est sur elle que s'appuie
tout cette émission elle connaît le
sujet des missions à lagord c'est un
moment comment un duel à mort au combat
battez contre vous même écoutez le
combat le plus divisé
c'est simple vous regardez notre
moniteur qui est un petit peu il ya des
couleurs drôle aujourd'hui un autre
militaire
dans l'esprit des fans finis en vidéo
miro cinq images dès que vous pensez
avoir de sujet des missions vous levez
la main vous criez d'accord c'est moi
tout le monde à la maison et au bureau
quand vous êtes à la mort c'est pas la
lune et c'est là ma maman bien et on
attend qu'on les appelle les gens qui
font ça l'est thanatos je suis poli
thanatologues je pense que ça écoute
c'est un sujet sur les unes et les
services funéraires ou c'est très
sérieux votre affaire
mais non c'est pas ça c'est parti c'est
pas sérieux c'est pas triste
c'est plein de couleurs c'est oui mais
attention c'est pas triste mais c'est le
sujet de film pour que si vous soulevez
beaucoup de questions qu'elle va
répondre durant cette émission
alors voici le thème c'est le nouveau
visage de la mort au canada tant que
sujet la bri anatole og les nouveaux
produits et mourir en santé non mourir
dans la dignité aussi ce soit pour une
prochaine émission
mais mourir beau beau bon pas cher c'est
le terme
bah oui oui ce que vaut un oui un peu
normal on n'a plus d'argent alors vaut
mieux faire ça 5 ça coûte trop cher
d'accord on va rire un peu même s'il
n'ya pas de quoi rire parce que si vous
êtes passés à travers ça dans le passé
avec un proche qui est décédé c'est bien
sûr d un cétacé le nouveau sujet
m'intéresse aussi
mais il est temps d'y songer parce que
le québec notamment s'est éloigné de la
religion et des rites religieux associé
à oum al amar 12 ans et donc ça donne un
nouveau visage un nouveau commerce
également grâce à ce qu'il est entrain
de transformation dans la vie canadienne
présentement je vais vous amener
attendait bourget où c'est quand on joue
il cette émission oui oui alors on est
prêt pour un duel
aujourd'hui vous êtes deux ils sont sûrs
de gala vous voulez perdre des points ou
gagner des points je pense qu'on va
rester sûr de perdre des points je sais
pas c'était vous avez 100 points
gagnants d' avance maintenant vous allez
perdre 20 points mais j'espère que non
mais il ya des voix six premières
questions de la grosse boule aujourd'hui
c'est le premier que je n'eus méreau un
voilà alors c'est très simple les façons
que nous avons disposé des 100 de nos
proches disparus évolué avec le temps et
où si avec les seize ans au canada ont
fait pas les mêmes choses l'hiver que le
bt quant à l'or il ya une une d'un
nouveau type très écologique est
maintenant disponible en magasin sur le
marché au canada un prix très
raisonnable pour une fraction du prix
des urnes conventionnelle voici la
question c'est un produit typiquement
canadien est ce une urne
une urne en poils de castor ça c'est à
sb une urne en copeaux d'érable sa peur
ou est ce c'est une urne en glace ou sa
glace et ça ne va pas rester à propos
des copeaux de bois je veux dire en
glace vous attire en glace et bien et on
y va on était qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
regarder on va regarder la vidéo de 0,2
on va vous montrer à quoi ça ressemble
et est ce qu'on fait avec cette urne qui
contient les cendres d'un proche qu'on
peut mettre dans plusieurs urnes en
glace on peut les diviser ans
aujourd'hui alors voilà c'est préparer
c'est une idée en partie à une idée
d'une de diane leclair bisson
il ya un reportage de qui accompagne la
page web de tam-tam aujourd'hui au sujet
de diane leclair bisson une entrevue de
raymond des marteaux elle est
anthropologue
elle s'intéresse beaucoup aux deux
années là voilà qui dépose dans l'eau
les cendres d'un proche
c'est le guide à suivre le guide de
faire le mode 2
[Musique]
on est là on est la seule à l'est après
ouais ok ça se dissout parce qu'à la
partie je sais pas si elle était au
salon de la mort il ya eu mon jeu vous
en savez des choses la main au québec
avec 1 7 décembre je suis en contrat il
c'était pendant le l'automne sa pensée
qu'on va demander notre invitée spéciale
elle présente aujourd'hui qui est l'un
au bout du skype au bout du téléphone au
bout du skype le voici
louis simon lamontagne bonjour monsieur
la montagne que cette urne
bonjour bonjour est ce que vous ne
proches est ce que dans plusieurs furent
mais on a un retour des missions
d'aujourd'hui non on entend que louis ce
qu'on a produit environ 80 secondes
reportage qui accompagne la non je ne
sais pas comment on peut faire pour
couper se signala de ressources en eau
claire buisson une entrevue de raymond
dell'arte alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
suggérer le savent il écrit il faut qu
ils un jour monsieur la montagne vous
écoutez notre émission je pense en ce
moment il vaut mieux couper le son sur
votre ordinateur peut être qu'ils
allaient me sens aimé ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va de la plaie on va même
pas ce que ça va mieux comme ça est ce
que vous nous entendez bien c'est bien
c'est fatah c'est qu'on a tué aussi nous
faudrait je pense c'est tellement l'air
juste une précision concernant la mort
c'était du 3 au 4 novembre
c'est bien c'est bien ça monsieur la
montagne du 3 au 4 novembre
enfin presque alors bon on a du
spécialiste de la russie en émission est
ce que c est ce que ça vous surfez en
serait si je dirais que vous êtes croque
mort
est ce qu'on peut dire ça ou non du tout
et je vous dirais même depuis qu'on a
fait une émission de télé un
documentaire et qui s'appelait les
croque-morts donc on aura mené les
herbes un peu plus populaires le ramener
à la mode
vous êtes propriétaire d'un salon
funéraire avec votre compagne
est ce que c'est bien le cas moi j'ai
pas regardé le documentaire à la tv le
moins ici sur nous sommes une famille
ces départs
moi et ma conjointe nous sommes nous
avons deux salons fier dans la région de
lanaudière disent oui donc tout quand on
meurt c'est automatique on se retrouve
chez vous il ya de la compétition
politique dans la région
mais on est la plus grande entreprise la
région de lanaudière
ça me fait penser à quelque chose oui
j'entends dans la région j'habite des
commerciaux à la radio et on entend un
propriétaire de maison finira qui dit je
suis à dire est un des rares qui reste
d'aider les salons de la région
il ya des grandes compagnies américaines
qui ont acheté plusieurs salons il ya un
grand commerce des multinationales oui
de la mort oui est ce que vous êtes
indépendant petit un gros comment vous
vous situez dans le marché actuellement
disons qu'au point de vue régional d'un
côté on est la plus grande entreprise
dans la région de l'auteur on était
dépendant on est toujours propriété
familiale 100 % québécoise
c'est sûr que quand on se compare aux
marchés du québec
on est peut-être dans l'île je dirais
les 50 40 ou 50 plus grandes entreprises
parce que c'est sûr que le poignet de
grandes entreprises se partagent une
grande partie du marché
quand on rentre dans les grands centres
comme montréal et québec a mais on dort
c'est alors il ya un peu moins de
compétition un petit peu moins de deux
roues jouarre est-ce que bonjour moi je
vu plusieurs reportages depuis quelques
temps parlant de l'industrie de la mort
du salon de la mort en disant que l'on
apprivoisé un peu plus facilement aux
différemment cette ce passage de la vie
hein
est ce que c'est un gag publicitaires ou
dans la réalité et des transformations
majeures dans notre industrie
il ya effectivement des transformations
majeures et un peu comme c'est sûr que
notre domaine étant très près de la
religion la laïcité de l'état et la
laïcité
des gens de plus en plus je vous dirais
que c'est ce qui fait un grand
changement si on peut cependant
comparatif qui est peut-être un peu plus
joyeux et à la mode si on compare au
mariage par exemple les mariages ont
sorti des églises depuis une quinzaine
d'années et étant donné que nous venons
n'est pas la même période de la vie ce
changement que les mariages ont eu
depuis 15-20 ans commence à recevoir
d'un monde fini
donc c'est le même si les gens veulent
se séparer la religion et le problème
que le domaine funéraire voruz je vous
dirai dans le passé c'est que on était
tellement liés et attaché de paix à la
religion dans l'idée des gens que quand
les gens voulu racheter les religions et
ont racheté leur ai dit qu'ils comme dit
rejeter le bébé avec l'eau du jour d'hui
on est on a appris le domaine funéraire
à se renouveler et à proposer des
services des rituels des commémorations
qui ne vont pas aux religieuses il ya
des gens pour qu'ils veulent religieuse
c'est important pour nous de pouvoir
proposer l'ensemble des possibilités
parce que on sert des gens qui ont entre
60 et 100 ans une personne de 97,1 qui
allait encore à la messe tous les jours
et toutes les dimanches pour elle ça va
être même les enfants vont dire pour est
très important d'aller à l'église et que
funérailles soient religieuses
al'inverse ont fait les funérailles de
quelqu'un de 60 ans ou de 50 ans ou même
des fois plus jeunes et vont dire mais
on veut sauf en chapelle à même le
complexe tuner est de plus en plus les
cérémonies en chapelles dans les salons
se veulent aussi laïque donc on a décelé
bradley qui viennent qui sont aucunement
à aucune affiliation religieuse qui fait
que la cérémonie ou même des fois c'est
la famille même aujourd'hui au plus de
limites
il ya plus de barrières avant sur mon
tailleur 25 et 30 ans jusqu'à ya 25 et
30 ans les fumeurs était pareil pour
tout le monde tout le monde est exposé
deux jours au salon troisième journée à
l'église ensuite enterré au cimetière
paroissial
la seule l'unique différence d'une
personne à l'autre était la couleur
cercueil
aujourd'hui chez nous ont fait 400
funérailles annuellement et je peux vous
dire qu'il y en aura pas deux pareils
dans l'année parce que tout peut changer
il ya aussi des bons diop on parle des
religions il ya aussi beaucoup de gens
qui arrivent au canada nous à radio
canada est en national ce sont ces
teintes clientèle auquel on s'adresse ce
tous les jours
les nouveaux immigrants les futurs
migrants si on est par exemple musulmans
est-ce que
ça tombe sous le sens de venir vous voir
en disant nous vous savez les
enterrements faut que ça se produise des
délais beaucoup plus court que dans la
tradition catholique est ce que vous
avez dû vous accommoder de oui c'est
certain que nous et en régions
l'immigration doute nous touchons un peu
mais ne nous touche pas encore beaucoup
je vous dirais c'est sûr qu'il ya eu par
exemple prendre l'exemple des musulmans
que dans la pure tradition musulmane le
corps doit être inhumé avant le coucher
du soleil la même journée au québec les
délais légaux font en sorte que c'est
impossible
donc on y va pour le plus rapidement
possible pour trouver le juste milieu
entre la loi et de la région et les
rituels donc mais comme je vous dis je
peux difficilement me prononcer sur les
rites de d'autres religions parce que
les communautés que nous avons dans
notre région vont être par exemple
italienne ukrainienne un peu polonais
qui sont très très très catholique
donc ça va être similaire ce qui est
universel en ce moment c'est l'arrivée
des nouvelles technologies
j'ai un vieux copain 84 ha de la famille
qui est décédé il ya quelques années on
a tous eu droit à la vidéo la
présentation de la vidéo lors de la
cérémonie et ensuite on avait la copie
de la vidéo de la cérémonie il y avait
plusieurs aspects vidéo dans cette
cérémonie là pour un homme qui était
quand même d'une autre génération
mais c'est pas seulement la vidéo qui
arrive au salon funéraire
j'imagine que il vous avait d'autres
demandes particulières de la part des
clients auxquels vous devez tenter de
répondre oui les deux montrent de plus
en plus et je vous dirais même quelque
chose que j'ai fait récemment
moi je vous dirai où s'envolent le
funéraire s'est produit sincèrement avec
la technologie les rituels funéraires
je reviens au même préparatifs qu'avec
les mariages s'en vont au delà comme on
a sorti des églises depuis quelques
années moi je pense que dans le futur va
sortir une suite des salons on sent
vaucluse vers l'événementiel
commémoratif que 20
une que les gens se solidifie aller dans
les deux complexes funéraires
par exemple un mariage peut se faire
dans un chapiteau derrière la maison
ça va être la même chose récemment j'ai
fait une célébration sur invitation
seulement d'une personne que c'est comme
ça qu'elle le voulait au musée d'art de
joliette dans une salle privée
les cendres étaient dans des bouteilles
de cristal avec un envol de ballons un
vidéo mémoire neuve qui cote est cette
personne voulait sort d'une personne en
fin de vie qui savait que ça s'en venait
à ce prix c'est une personne quand même
de 2,60 d'une soixantaine d'années et
elle elle voulait absolument être
complètement différent et complètement
ailleurs lorsqu'on voit normalement je
disais sa famille que je le trouvais
très avant gardiste parce que moi je
pense qu'on s'en va au verso c'est
l'événementiel avons grandi dans la
technologie a toujours sa place
est ce qu'elle vaut la garder ou est-ce
que ça va vraiment se développer
oui de plus en plus de choses et
plateformes web lé commémorative des
choses comme ça ça vaut garder sa place
ça va être le mais je pensais toujours
les gens ont besoin de se rencontrer
moi j'ai assisté à un enterrement ou la
famille qui était loin d'ici à là suivi
par skype le long terme en est ce que
vous vous avez ce genre de huy de
demandes parfois ok donc oui ça arrive
ça arrive c'est quand même assez simple
aujourd'hui avec par exemple les la
technologie et rome c'est facile de
l'installer dans une chapelle dans une
salle de cérémonie pour que les gens un
peu partout sur la planète des membres
de la famille peut suivre la cérémonie à
distance il ya même d'une entreprise qui
se spécialise dans les caméras hd
installés qui installe dans les
complexes funéraires avec une plateforme
web pour aujourd'hui tout est possible
mais peut-être aussi quelque chose qui a
changé votre profession s'est il ya de
plus en plus un souci de par rapport à
l'environnement parce que je me trompe
ou par rapport à intégrer
l'environnement après la mort et aussi
par rapport à polluer à peu prendre trop
d'espacés les cercueils
est ce que vous voyez une différence
puis oui mais je vous dirais que souvent
eu beaucoup de
mauvaise boîte d'acception par rapport à
ce bouquet par exemple les gens vont
dire qu'est ce qui est le plus
écologique mais a déjà montré le plus
écologique ça va être la crémation ou
maintenant la crémation
mais la réalité est que le plus
écologique passion traditionnel avec
cercueils biodégradables
pourquoi c'est que la crémation dégage
du co2 la crémation gras des grandes
quantités d'eau avec des produits
chimiques aussi pour des spots soudain
corps tandis que l'inhumation on
reconnaît de la matière organique donc
une animation traditionnelle dans un
cercueil écologique avec une bonne main
ou soit aucune envie ou un engouement
avec des produits écologiques qui disent
aussi c'est ce qu'il ya de plus éco et
bio qu'on retrouve présentement le
problème comme tout ce qui est bio
malheureusement eu un coût qui est
rattachée les par exemple les produits
qu'on doit utiliser quand une famille
nous demande ça sont beaucoup plus
dispendieux
les cercueils étant donné tout le qui
sont certifiés ce qu'on appelle c'est en
anglais green bio sont plus dispendieux
de faire le processus et la
certification il possède comme quand on
achète des bananes bio coûtent plus cher
que des bananes ossements fait c'est
certain que ça amène une dimension que
les gens veulent comme vous disiez
tantôt moins dépenser un peu sur les tue
elle finira mais cet aspect l'eau
malheureusement est un peu plus
dispendieux pas des tonnes mais quand
même un peu
et pour ce qui est du visuel un cercueil
billon c'est certain que immo est beau
qu'un cercueil traditionnel comme mon
repos par exemple de rien à voir qui est
verni avec des doreurs cette review ya
pas de métal il ya en fait un minimum de
métal il n'y a pas de vernis on y lit
certifiés biologiques
mais dans les grandes villes est ce que
votre toujours avoir à cet espace pour
l'inhumation d'un cercueil sens que oui
les méthodes sont quand même con sus de
cette façon-là de que ce soit avec les
lots parce que oui c'est sur un look
perpétuelle de fêtes familiales
il va finir par avoir une limite mais
quand on y va avec un lot les lots qui a
fait le temporaire au bout de 25 ans ils
peuvent par ce qu'on appelle le
survêtement d'ossements et mettre le
cercueil
donc oui de l'espace y en a un jour
c'est certain qu'on va arriver à une
certaine limite mais je pense qu on est
formé la veille
attendez attendez on va se parler de
surbaissement d'ossements moi je j'y
tiens quand même 25 ans je trouve que
c'est pas tellement longtemps s'est pas
99 ans qu'est ce que c'est que cette
formule et ça coûte doit pas coûter cher
ou quoi en fait ce qu'ils appellent de
surbaissement dos mais sait on le voit
dans les grands cimetières justement qui
ont qui risque d'avoir un problème d'
espace averses ou de la religion dit on
le sait que au bout de 25 ans s'ils ont
besoin de l'espace ils vont creuser
ils vont récupérer les ossements ils
vont creuser un peu plus creux il met
les ossements pour ensuite mettre un
autre cercueil
si ce qui était leur surbaissement
d'ossements d'accord et bas à paris je
sais qu'ils ont eue c'est une technique
il empile les gens depuis des années on
n'enlève pas le nom des anciens enfin de
vous des premiers mois comment ça
fonctionne c'est cet aspect en fait
c'est n'est pas ça ici les catacombes
comme on voit paris effectivement mais
si je me trompe pas et je préparais à
l'autre avant mon chapeau mais je pense
que les catacombes
il n'en est plus présentement de
documents dans les catacombes
c'est que quand je pense qu'on va
montrer dix huit ou dix neuvième siècle
il y avait un problème à paris d'odeurs
étant donné que les défunts étaient
placés dans des mausolées et ceux qui
n'étaient pas en terre était vraiment
temps décrypte et la surpopulation des
cimetières et puis bon l'hygiène à
l'époque et faisait en sorte que y ont
dû ressortir les ossements des
cimetières aussi pour des espaces parce
que sont quand même ça te l'avais dit
beaucoup plus vieille que montréal par
exemple ont transporté les ossements
dans les catacombes ils les ont empilé
comme on veut les voir encore
aujourd'hui aller visiter c'est à ces
couloirs le souterrain mais les
catacombes
oui je ne pense pas qu'ils font encore
descendre encore des mâles sur la
montagne je vous écoute évidemment avec
toutes ces explications scientifiques et
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de sourire en
coin
je sais que c'est pas très sain de ma
part c'est un sujet très sérieux mais à
vous êtes habitués aux gens qui rient
quand même avec vous vous avez fait une
série télévisée où l'objectif était
justement de rendre les choses plus
humaine oui en fait qu'on voulait
c'était démontrer les gens tellement de
l'idée préconçue sur nous sur le mode
mon domaine funéraire les thanatologues
en général notre but était vraiment de
démontrer aux gens que premièrement on
n'est pas la famille adams ou des
vampires qui y dorment deux jours et
travaille de nuit on voulait vraiment
montré qu' on est des personnes comme
les autres et effectivement le monde
finira d'aujourd'hui n'est plus ce qu'il
était et tous les gens de ben et les
idées préconçues que les gens peuvent
avoir sur nous vient du feu sont de
notre à autre la porte du domaine
funéraire pendant genre je pense à mon
grand père que tout devait être secrète
devait être cachés et quand on cache des
informations quand on cache des choses
aux gens ils vont se faire leur propre
idée des boîtes a fallu donc on s'est
dit on va le montrer si on met cartes
sur table les gens pourront pas dire
qu'ils savent pas et puis c'est pour ça
qu'on est embarqué dans le projet de
l'émission justement pour pouvoir
montrer et ouvrir les portes qui
actuellement sont clôturées mental pour
vous est-ce que la perception de la mort
a changé depuis ces dernières années est
ce que les gens sont confrontés à la
mort au moment où elle survient je parle
pas de ceux qui meurent mais de la
famille de la société en général est ce
que maintenant on est on en parle plus
de la mort aux césars as toujours un
tabou mais moi je dirais c'est certain
que ma perception est biaisé parce
qu'étant donnée justement que j'en parle
ouvertement les gens m'en parlent
beaucoup dans la trahison le commun des
mortels est ce que les gens parlent plus
et tout ça je ne sais pas mais je sais
que les gens apprécient beaucoup les
principes de justement qu'on en parle et
que c'est comme faut en parler au fond
peut pas cacher ce qui se passe et puis
de toujours vouloir vivre dans le déni
sans vouloir en parler c'est pour mieux
non plus c'est certain que demande un
souper de famille dimanche soir c'est
pas un sujet prioritaire
la cote du plaisir de parler de la mort
vous parler de ce qu'on voudrait comme
rituel funéraire
mais c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut pas vous avez dit salon votre
famille possède dix salons funéraires
combien de personnes mortes vous pensent
entre les mains chaque année environ 4,4
de plus de quatre ans donc ça veut dire
que vous vous êtes occupés mais vous
avez le temps de prendre soin de chaque
personne
vous pouvez avoir des fois seulement une
ou deux personnes qui passent dans un
salon par som par semaine par exemple
oui oui parce qu'il ya des salons autant
comme on a des salons qui sont un peu
plus grands ont dans le complexe qui est
un type vraiment peu comme ce qu'on peut
retrouver dans les grands centres avec
deux grands salons chatel salle de
réception comme on a aussi des salons de
chapelle de villages qui sont ouverts
seulement lorsque quelques îles et
excuser je parle des villages comme
celle beatrix ou
saint-alphonse-rodriguez comme
l'utilisent que quelques jours dans
l'année je dirais même mais ce sont ces
[ __ ] sont couverts emplettes mais oui
effectivement on a le temps de s'occuper
des gens ont une bonne équipe avec nous
si on s'entendait pas seulement la
famille
on est en tout une douzaine une équipe
et la chance que nous avons c'est que
les gens qui travaillent avec nous sont
tout aussi passionnés par leur métier
que nous nous sommes donc c'est certain
que ça fait un beau travail d'équipé
peu importe le métier la passion ça se
sent merci beaucoup monsieur la montagne
de nous avoir mis au parfum de ce qui se
passe dans votre industrie s'était donc
louis simon lamontagne
pour moi les résidences thériault
incorporé résidence funéraire à moi je
pense c'était très agréable comme
contactez moi j'ai un peu la charge du
pôle
je ne peux un petit peu que ça tu peux
parce que on va venir ça loin pour
un autre espace sujet tabou rien de
passer ça pas vraiment mais c'est un
petit peu énervant
comme il dit il faut en parler
êtes vous prêt pour avoir du plaisir
moi je suis à 87 à 81 il est donc temps
pour un interne pour cette deuxième
roulement contenir peut-être il ya trois
roulements de boules par émission voici
le deuxième
combien de canadiens meurent chaque
année on a entendu dans son commerce et
400 mais c'est très loin du total
alors combien de canadiens meurent
chaque année c'est le thème de cette
deuxième question un prix un peu un pour
vous aider à pré en bulles le nombre de
décès au canada a atteint un sommet en
2014 et un autre sommet en 2016 selon
statistique canada
et on dit que le total annuel et vont
continuer à augmenter comme ça en
fonction du vieillissement de la
population et du nombre au cid
exactement en et 37 36 millions de
canadiens d'accord
combien de canadiens meurent chaque
année 2014 2016
est ce que c'était a autour de 250 mille
décès est-ce que c'était bon autour de
500 mille décès ou est-ce que c'était
c'est au tour de 750000 des 5
je sais qu'au québec c'est 66 me quelque
chose comme ça 66000 à tous et parce
qu'il y avait un papier de vraiment
qu'il avait fait remarquer et le
population canadienne ses 23 % de la
population totale la protéger moi je
veux dire ah je pense que c'est parce
que c'est à peu près le nombre
d'immigrants qui a beaucoup de chance
quand on n'a pas la réponse suffit
d'utiliser son intelligence c'est
effectivement alors c'est 250 9200 2014
et 267000 en 2016 à la diction contrôle
le 1er janvier on a eu 900 bébés qui
sont nés au canada en une seule journée
et on s'attend donc si on fait le total
le bilan d'une année c'est combien de
bébés ça qu'ils vont être 900 x 900 x
faites-le l'unicef a dit qu'il y aurait
à peu près 1000 bébés par jour j'ai du
temps article c'est ça hein
i365 mais ça va être beaucoup de gens là
aussi on a des impôts en fait des
entrées de sortie aussi donc ça des
interrogations qui sortent au 6 février
les gens qui sortent de façon naturelle
sans passer par le chrono moi ça m'a
angoissé mais vraiment jamais bien sexy
et je voulais vous demander si vous êtes
d'accord avec cette nouvelle tendance
dans le monde
chic des salons funéraires je vais vous
présenter la vidéo numéro attend dé voir
que je vois je pensais la prochaine ça
va être celle de la numéro c'est numéro
4 que ce qu'elle dit numéro 4 second
portrait ego portrait avec les mots oui
avec les morts on va regarder ce que ça
donne un peu mais je sais pas je vous
demandais ce que vous en pensez mais
aussi des esgaulx portraits pris il ya
deux ans et à ce moment là qu'on a
commencé à se plaindre du côté des
thanatologues on voit la sas est aux
états unis et il ya d'autres qui ont été
filmées au canada dans tous ses messages
ses personnels je sais pas si c'est avec
le sourire que voler avec g à gramat et
puis des fois faut lire les commentaires
qui accompagnent sur facebook les photos
alors des fois c'est terrible dans une
des photos qui s'en vient ça c'est ça on
va dire la beach est morte suture sa
belle mère alors c'est de donner tout le
monde est souriant général moi je serais
plutôt triste sais pas si ça regarde la
digne elle dit mords moi c'est le moment
souci c'est la dignité du mort mon souci
c'est heures
franchement ce qu'on devrait pas nous on
le monde parce que c'est une émission
d'information wii ce titre la commande
ces images là je vous dis honnêtement
mais l'association des thanatologues du
québec s'est opposé à cette
cette tendance une fois j'ai fait j'ai
fait un reportage photo sur internet aux
logs d'instruments finira mais il était
interdit il était interdit de prendre
les photos des desmarais même une
parcelle du corps normalement interdit
qu'on a cessé disponible sur facebook et
sur les réseaux sociaux
je suis intéressé à vous montrer
maintenant notre image de la semaine on
va découvrir ensemble notre image la
semaine on ne monte pas tout de suite
vous devez deviner et où ça comme un
casse tête au foot est d'abord ya pas de
point d'accès de se souvenir un peu de
l'actualité puis on essaie de voir qu
est ce qu a été dans les médias un photo
autour de photos de la semaine ça se
passe au canada et c'est lié au sujet de
la mort cette semaine
donc ça tombe bien une belle consistance
on a marqué mon site je répond par oui
ou par non à vos questions pour deviner
quel est cet te faut on va en un peu de
musique pour rapport un peu de
croque-mort là-dedans voilà c'est qu'est
mort cette semaine
ces sujets liés à mon sujet l'idée d'un
grand calme parce que c'est logique je
connais pas excusé
[Musique]
poser des questions aux quais alors
juste des personnes de personnes ou
d'animaux type de personne à personne où
deux personnes deux personnes en même
temps morte en même temps elles ne sont
pas mortes a donc ce n'est pas une
tragédie s'agit-il une fragile trêve ça
aurait pu être tragique pour elle a
marre d'être voilà c'est la
l'adolescente avec un camp des récentes
mais un homme et une femme qui a frôlé
la mare faut les lamas cdma sur le pan
de non c'était opa sur un pont sur la
route wii continue sa belle voix j'ai
vraiment pas coûter ligne verte ans il y
avait sur l'île d'orléans ça c'est dit
c'est pas au québec
c'est pas au québec c'est nord-ouest
dans l'ouest nous par une une élite bas
il n'y a pas qu'à l'ouest l'est et le
centre restaurateurs y au canadien une
panne d'avion en auto ok non non et non
alors oui sur une autoroute ça va bien
oui un accident avec un orignal un axe
heure avec quelque chose et n'ont rien à
faire ni mal c'était plutôt minérale à
une roche
non ben alors tu as fait c'était plus
doux mais plus + transgénèse pas non à
la casse est tombée dans love sur la
voiture y avait m
oui oui oui il enquêtait sur un camion
la commune c'est ça combien une plaque
en bois quelque chose qui est tombée sur
une plaque en bois qui tombait sur le
pare brise du véhicule la région de
toronto
on regarde ça donne parce que là on va
voir si ça s'est passé
la beatles and oui c'est ça alors sur
saône oui je n'aurai pas à oui je le
veux c'est vrai que c'est une image
bottes blessure aurier oui mais ça fait
pas partie de notre jus de la grosse
boule n'ont manqué
[Rires]
tu es pour 50% minimum de temps vous
allez voir je pense que là j'ai des
images filmées par tous les réseaux
ajout du tout le monde a montré ça et
parce que c'est arrivé au bon milieu des
deux candidats des deux passagers le
conducteur
ça c'est une image en floride en octobre
dernier même incident là aussi pas de
blessé rien le conducteur s'en est
sauvée complètement il a refusé d'aller
l'hôpital et finalement tout va bien ça
se produit genre d'histoires d'horreur
de ça parce que tu n'y es pour rien
c'est comme comme le celui qui le voit
il vient vers toi et les ce qu'ils
appellent les igloos roule assez les
voitures qui sont à peine déneigé
puis avec la vitesse sur le toit ça peut
se détacher en bloc
c'est juste qu'on pousse heures oui oui
mais il ya des amendes pour ça les
camionneurs doivent dégager le haut de
leur camion au jour sur un gros glaçon
il ya 5 6 ans a fait une grosse demande
qu'est ce que tu veux faire un instant
la diro monsieur c'est ta faute
là j'ai acheté une caméra sur mon
véhicule justement en fonction des deux
personnes
l'estonie maintenant je pense que la
caméra va être utilisée de plus en plus
les assurances tout ça vers ça devrait
être obligatoire
il ya un pays où c'est pratiquement je
pense la russie lance à outrance parce
qu'ils peuvent pas faire confiance même
aux policiers
non faut pas faut pas charrier des
fausses idées des gens pas confiance aux
autres on a vu trop d'incidence produits
rouler le foot c'est feu déguerpis
naissance arrêté on est prêts pour le
dernier jeu d'accord mais alors combien
on rappelle les scores 80 80 parce que
c'est à ça qu'on n'est pas là c'est pas
de vous rappeler des disques du score de
l'autre suffit de vous rappeler de votre
papa alors ça et 80 très bien alors
dernière question arriver entre sk non
quelqu'un il va dit si vous voulez les
stats des morts est né sans oublier
stade canada à saint urbain il répond
par déduction totale
kiki qui nous a écrit comme ça passait
ou à l'hymne à sa famille ses amis et on
est sur facebook maintenant alors je
sais pas comment ce qui se présente
maintenant c'est un gars hyper actif sur
facebook et les médias sociaux
il invite ses amis le salut bombe à
éviter de continuer à inviter des amis
pour vous aider comme sa démission
dernière question on va voir si vous
avez répondu celle ci quel est l'âge
3,50 points à perdre accord quel est
l'âge chez les canadiens durant lequel
survient le plus grand nombre de décès à
quel âge là vous devez vous méfier le
plus
quel ça pourrait vous arriver c'est
différent chez les hommes et chez les
femmes mais dans l'ensemble
à quel âge selon vous lorsqu'on est né
un canadien ont cours le plus le risque
de passer de l'autre côté est ce que
c'est à 76 ans est ce que ces bébés 84
ans reste beaucoup de temps ou est-ce
que c'est ses 90 ans
c est ce qu on parle de l'espérance de
vie c'est sympa de l'espérance de vie on
parle de l'année c'est arrivé à un
certain âge et vos risques de mourir
sont plus élevés cette année toutes
autres années je savais pas que c'était
cette statistique existe ça existe
monsieur ce serait à pour vous et pour
vous ce serait là aussi parce que c'est
bon allez va partie de ces passionnés
magique mais j'ai l'espérance
l'espérance allait aller au delà de 80
tours de jeu par 76 vers les versions
sur les 76 votes eh bien vous perdez
tous les deux 50 points puisque la bonne
réponse c'est 84 et 90 84 chez les
hommes 90 ans chez les femmes mais
l'espérance de l'espérance de vie pour
les femmes des 83 ans pour les hommes de
79 ans mais l'année où courir plus de
risques de passer des parce que - oui
mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
rendent même pas 84 oui ils font pas
partie de la table a statistiquement
parce qu'il ya ceux qui meurent à deux
jours de semaine
c'est un plus grand bassin de gens à mon
âge à 2 à 32 ans il ya peut-être 20 % de
risques seulement que je décède d'accord
ok mais l'année suivante et peut-être
21% et finalement finalement l'espérance
de vie c'est une moyenne dans wii de
comprendre si l'on peut faire une
émission spéciale sur l'espérance de vie
la semaine poche c'est trop rapproché je
pense qu'on peut gagner et un score de
32 30
je pensais même pas tant je pensais
vraiment se trouve au juste avant qu'on
se quitte je pense qu'on pourrait avoir
le temps présenté la vidéo manolo 6
parce que c'est utile pour tout le monde
pour ceux qui nous regardent sur le web
de savoir qu'il ya une application
maintenant disponible pour écouter dans
les différentes langues de radio canada
international différents produits
notamment cette émission sur android et
sur l'examen grosse d'ordinateurs comme
moi vous faites comme ça si vous voulez
pour trouver vous pouvez accéder très
rapidement sur votre téléphone
intelligent à notre contenu
extraordinaire où est l'argent pas mal
depuis trois ans depuis chaque fois que
j'en parle j'ai pas encore ça se monte
de phase iib je le mets ce qui est bien
c'est que d'encre elle télécharge les
articles dont type tu n'es pas obligé
d'être connecté au moment où tu
consultes ça c'est bien ça dans le bus
mince ça permet de de revoir ce que j'ai
fait sur les fautes d'orthographe
parfois je consulte pas ben voilà c'est
tout pour cette semaine
ça a été extrêmement agréable malgré le
fait qu'ils avaient une équipe réduite
merci beaucoup à sylvain notre
technicien qui a bien fait ça merci
beaucoup à marie-claude plaisir soutien
technique également aux côtés web et
puis samir ben c'est très gentil
si stéphane et merci à nos auditeurs et
puis merci aussi aux hadiths qui nous a
fait la surprise dire merci